so we're given this equation here what i
want you to do is pause this video and
see if you can solve it what x x values
satisfy the equation
all right now let's work through this
together
so one technique could be just let's
just try to complete the square here on
the left hand side so to do that let me
write it this way x squared
minus 8x
and then i have
all right the plus 1 out here is equal
to
85
now if i want to complete the square i
just have to think what can i add to
both sides of this equation that could
make this part of the left-hand
expression a perfect square
well if i look at this negative 8
coefficient on the first degree term i
could say okay let me take half of
negative 8 that would be negative 4 and
then negative 4 squared is going to be
positive 16. so i'm going to add a
positive 16 on the left hand side and if
i want i could then subtract a 16 from
the left hand side or i could add a 16
on the right hand side notice i've just
done the same thing to both sides of
this equation
and why was that useful
well now what i've just put in
parentheses is a perfect square this is
the same thing as x minus 4 squared it
was by design we looked at that negative
8 half of that is negative 4 you square
it you get 16. and you can verify x
minus 4 times x minus 4 is indeed equal
to this
and then we have plus 1 is going to be
equal to what's 85 plus 16
that is 101
and now we want to get rid of this one
on the left-hand side and the easiest
way we can do that is subtract 1 from
both sides that way we'll just isolate
that x minus 4 squared and we are left
with
x minus 4 squared
4 squared these
cancel out is going to be equal to
100.
now if something squared is equal to 100
that means that the something is equal
to the positive or the negative square
root of 100 or that that something
x minus 4 is equal to positive or
negative
positive or negative 10. all i did is
took the plus or minus square root of a
hundred and this makes sense if i took
positive 10 squared i'll get 100 if i
take negative 10 squared i get 100. so x
minus 4 could be either one of those and
now i just add 4 to both sides of this
equation
and then what do i get
i get x
is equal to
4
plus or minus 10. or another way of
thinking about it i could write it as x
is equal to 4 plus 10 is 14
and then 4 minus 10
is equal to negative 6.
so these are two ways to solve it but
there's other ways to solve this
equation we could right from the get go
try to
subtract 85 from both sides some people
feel more comfortable solving quadratics
if they have the quadratic expression be
equal to zero
and if you did that you would get x
squared
minus 8x
minus 84
is equal to 0. all i did is i subtracted
85 from both sides of this equation to
get this right over here now this one we
can approach in two different ways we
can complete the square again or we
could just try to factor if we complete
the square we're going to see something
very similar to this actually let me
just do that really fast if i look at
this part right over there i could say x
squared minus
eight
x
and then once again half of negative
eight is negative four that squared is
plus sixteen
and then i'd have minus eighty-four let
me do that in that blue color so we can
keep
track minus 84 and then if i added 16 on
the left hand side i could either add
that to the right hand side so both
sides have 16 added to it or
if i want to maintain the equality i
could just subtract 16 from the left
hand side
so i've added 16 subtracted 16 i haven't
changed the left hand side's value and
then that would be equal to 0.
this part right over here this is x
minus 4 squared
this part right over here
is minus 100
is
equal to zero and then you add 100 to
both sides of this and you get exactly
this step right over here
now another way that we could have
approached it without completing the
square
we could have said x squared minus 8x
minus 84 is equal to zero
and think about what two numbers if i
multiply them i get negative 84 so
they'd have to have different signs
since when i take their product i get a
negative number and when i add them
together i get negative 8. and there we
could just look at the factorization of
negative 84 of 84 generally it could be
2 times let's just think about 84. 84
could be 2 times 42 and obviously one of
them would have to be negative one of
them would have to be positive in order
to get to negative 84 but the difference
between these two numbers if one was
positive and one is negative is a lot
more than eight so that doesn't work so
let's try
let's see i'll do a few in my head
three times 28 but still that difference
is way more than eight
four
times
four times let's see
four times 21. now that difference
between 4 and 21 is still larger than 8.
let's see 5 doesn't go into it's 6
times 14. that's interesting now okay so
let's think about this so 6 times 14 is
equal to 84. one of them has to be
negative and since
our when we take the sum of the two
numbers we get a negative number that
means the larger one is negative
so let's see 6 times negative 14 is
negative 84
6 plus negative 14 is indeed equal to
negative eight so we can factor this as
x plus six
times x
minus 14 is equal to zero
and so the product of two things is
equal to zero that means
what if either of them is equal to zero
that would make the entire expression
equal to zero so we could say x plus six
is equal to zero or x minus 14 is equal
to zero subtract six from both sides
here we get x is equal to negative 6 or
add 14 to both sides here or x is equal
to 14. exactly what we got up here